I feel sweaty let's judge celebrities hi
guys my name is freestyle we do not know
now you know your life different now
it's the word show season so there's a
lot of fashion reviews on my channel and
they don't stop today because over the
weekend the Billboard Music Awards
happen and a lot of curiously notable
people wore some curious clothing
curiosity did kill the cat curiosity was
the name of the snake that the cat owner
also had in his house let's judge
fashion cally Steinfeld Easter things
he's singing feel senior non sternum how
do you say her last name let's see how
many contradictory comments we can get
going in the comments section thank you
and we always look great an award shows
in my opinion as this is no different I
feel like every word show her eyebrow
expert kidding further towards her ears
and temples I don't hate it sure it's
just to make you look like a very high
fashion amoeba oh that's one sexy
endoplasmic reticulum get it girl it
looks like you got some spooky avocados
just slow it all over your tip area
that's cute
very California and then in your vaginal
regions you just got a bunch of those
screaming guys from that famous
screaming painting just with no hand
also kind of looks like you're a
colorblind test where they show you this
weird scribbly image you could try and
find the number inside the video
Nicole story first that sure is Nicole
flushing shirt choosing choosing
Scherzinger there while I want to call
shirt is Enya with those fun bags
your skin looks Ashley boobs beautiful
so healthy and long you're glowing I
could see a bright light coming from the
two headlights this is a little bit like
you took party like crepe paper like a
color like no one wanted to decorate
their party with and you're like there's
a lot of this left at michaels so i'll
make this into a thing that's on my body
very settle for tipsy Salvatore this is
Diplo
I have learned that this is not Joseph
gordon-levitt doing a Draco Malfoy
impression I had no idea that this would
Diplo look like you look at Colonel
Sanders
Skrillex like a Gandalf word DJ or sold
real estate in Beverly Hills yeah but
that's a Hudgens well our gift to the
world this looks like you had sex with
your prom date in the 70s in like the
back of a white limo that your parents
rented for you and the dress got all
kind of shoveled and you just said yes
to that dress get it girl Lindsey
Stirling oh my god one I love Lindsey
Stirling so goddamn much - she looks
absolutely beautiful this is gorgeous I
love you with blonde hair like Victorian
Little Red Riding Hood like I'm not good
at describing everything Linda just
released a documentary called brave
enough which is on YouTube red so go
check it out if you haven't seen it
already - justice on the podcast talking
about it and I just can't say enough
good things about her and you look great
you look like a mermaid got legs went up
on land found the state sale from an old
woman that passed away by ourselves and
saw this table thoughts emitted into her
dresses showed up at the Bluebird Music
Awards Lea Michele let's confuse and
lost my [ __ ] there and I'm sure it's a
good time what's this dress I like this
dress because it's very subtle and it's
confusion with itself
like so much of the concept of strapless
dress and said let's do the opposite
let's do all straps dress cute whoa what
is that
whoahhh right Rita Ora okay I know this
is like a Craigslist
Demi Lovato impersonator but Rita Ora I
like this this is cool ginseng in a
matador up top then into the oh I forgot
my pants
so I'll just wear the flips that I have
again yeah cute Olivia Munn is they're
one of the greatest musicians of our
time I like living mine I think she's
cool airy boudoir like you own a really
sophisticated brothel Ansel Elgort
absolutely brought an slur I don't know
how to say things Ansel Elgort you you
look very serious like you
so your nemesis show up on the red
carpet
pink carpet my bad everybody should go
back to Hanoi Stan Stan fields outfit
and season qualified this is a no no my
nemesis stamp and you're nailing it you
teach at college today palsy whoa
everyone forget half of their outfit is
that the thing this is like you might
have been kidnapped and you broke free
in time to get to the Dover Music Awards
and you found someone with a trench coat
and you just tied it around your way and
then yet you were all save your legs
look stressful took all the rope that
did you tied up with you just wrapped it
all around your legs like these are now
shoes you John Legend oh it's like thank
you so content with what's going on
also always dress is very cool a navy
plaid suit something like that you look
like a blueprint and I will build you up
I just write a love song if you enjoy
those lyrics John Legend please reach
out to me over my social media every
topic across all social media Thank You
Rachel Platten
I like this dress a lot although most of
your other slaves you look like modern
Spanish kitchen tile and I think that's
really cute tell me like a bell oh look
how sexy this is you beautiful look it
went you early sexy like burlesque bar
and the shoulder curtains and you ran
out you made him a dress cute Ashley
Tisdale this is very Paula Abdul Miss
Christina Aguilera and I don't hate it
no Cyrus whoa there's pink meets
powerful business dad Q what a look
silly my Cyrus mm looks like Billy Ray
Cyrus or I said this before about the
very stars on a carpet and awards show a
worthless sunglass so I don't believe
that's actually Billy right Cyrus I
think this is an impersonator really
this is a guy that owns like a barbecue
food truck
just found some parking outside the
venue inside to walk down the carpet
everyone's like oh that's really Syrus
you're like okay I'll put only my thumbs
in my pocket and go with it
what oh of course this is Machine Gun
Kelly because what is what she and gun
Kelly I've heard of as a thing I didn't
know if it was a man or woman a band or
adult it was really angry about the fact
that this suit looks like it's made from
that expensive gift wrap paper that you
get my potterybarn.com yeah Rebecca
Black oh look at this sexy businesswoman
Noah Cyrus got the business bad pants
and then she took the business that
blazer was like I don't need these
shoulders cute well there you go there
is my review of the red pink carpet
fashions at the Billboard Music Awards
let me know in the comments down below
who was your favorite look I care about
you this video thumbs up like these
fashion reviews and subscribe to this
YouTube channel because I make videos
Monday Wednesday and Friday
sometimes thanks for being here guys I
don't know or like end attender ticular
endoplasmic reticulum we got there